on prime crime
oh my gosh it's the shooting captured on
real-time audio
i was like aim and i put that front
sight right in the center mast
and i squeezed i i think i believe two
rounds
was this self-defense or a crime
this sounds and looks like a staged
event
hey there everybody i'm jesse weber and
welcome to prime crime
this is where we do a deeper dive into
the most high profile and memorable true
crime cases
there are so many stories we cover where
we say we wish we could have gotten that
on tape
this is one of those times we actually
have it
thank you for calling hmt website
assistance this is maddie may have your
mobile number to better assist you
a car breaks down a driver calls for
help happens all the time
across this country and no one bats an
eye but on october 18
2015 in palm beach gardens florida
this call would become a crucial piece
of evidence
in a major case and what's the name on
it
corey jones 31 year old drummer corey
jones was driving south on the i-95
freeway
after finishing up a set with his
bandmates as he's headed
south he begins to have car trouble and
pulls off to the side of the road
i'm off of the pga uh
as jones stays on the line with roadside
assistance little does he
or the operator realize what's about to
happen
officer nouman raja a seven-year police
veteran
had been working an undercover
surveillance operation nearby
raja takes notice of jones car and
decides to investigate
he would later say he believed the
vehicle was abandoned
the mode that he goes into is to drive
the wrong way
up this ramp park himself diagonally off
the corner the front corner of the car
now this is a practice that you would do
in a tactical emergency
when you've got to block a fleeing
vehicle or a potentially fleeing vehicle
to say then that oh i thought the car
was abandoned would be inconsistent with
his actions which was to come in
hard and aggressive dressed in plain
clothes and with no badge
raja parks's unmarked van gets out and
approaches jones
what he doesn't know is the next several
minutes are being recorded by roadside
assistance
[Music]
oh my gosh raja fires three shots at
jones
then another volley
[Music]
corey jones is shot dead
the shooting would wake up guests at a
nearby hotel
hi i'm at the um the doubletree hotel
and we heard gunshots outside our window
there's a guy walking backwards holding
a gun
now the question is why did raja kill
jones
as investigators sort through the
evidence it becomes clear
something isn't right first there's
raja's phone call to 9-1-1 dispatch
which he dials in approximately 33
seconds
after firing the last round
right now this is garden
this is gardens alpha 1. i just got one
down i just shot one person
i'm at that off ramp right behind
doubletree blackmail
there are inconsistencies in what he's
telling that dispatcher
versus what we hear and heard on the
audio
on the offense gave me some units i've
lost contact with him i don't know where
he is
all right you got it buddy he's claiming
uh i don't know where
jones went i lost a line of sight
on him um that may appear to be
inconsistent he had put several rounds
um downrange and into into jones
where's your radio raj my radio's in the
van right now i don't have it with me
that's what i'm on the phone all right
stay on the phone buddy any
well-trained police officer well-meaning
police officer
understands the key importance of having
that radio
on you when you're going to act in a
lawful capacity
so number one the very fact that we're
talking about him calling
9-1-1 on his cell phone is an indication
that something was wrong with his
mindset when he approached
uh jones's vehicle he knew that call was
going to be recorded
so he made sure to play up his version
of events to
create the record that raja was acting
in self-defense
according to raja jones pulled a gun on
him
i came out i saw him come out with a
handgun i gave him commands i identified
myself
and he turned pointed the gun at me
started running i shot him
investigators would find jones licensed
380 caliber handgun at the site
but they would conclude that it hadn't
been fired and was positioned
125 feet from jones body
the autopsy would reveal that raja shot
jones
three times hitting him in both arms and
the fatal shot
going through his heart and lungs law
enforcement officers
are trained that the threat is not
neutralized
until that person has dropped the weapon
um or no longer poses a threat to you
and others so i think there's a common
misperception among the public that you
could never shoot somebody
in the back or shoot a fleeing felon um
you can
however someone who is has been running
away from you
has not fired any shots at you and now
you are
subsequently after initially firing
rounds
you are continuing to fire someone who
is now
a distance away or running in the other
direction of you
seems inconsistent with it with a
pending or
imminent threat after shooting jones
it's particularly strange then that raja
barks commands
as if he's still alive roger you're all
right
yeah man i'm good i'm good on the off
ramp right
it's very difficult here to not conclude
that this sounds and looks like a staged
event
if you combine the 33 second delay in
calling
uh for help um with what he verbalized
in that call for help which is drop the
gun
drop the gun and then by the way in the
same call he says what
i lost him i may have lost him i can't
see him
okay well which is it the crime scene
afterwards the gun is found
um and and has been dropped so we
these all seem inconsistent to me
undercover palm beach gardens police
officer nouman raja
opened fire on stranded motorist corey
jones ultimately killing him
the morning after the incident raja
conducts a crime scene walkthrough with
investigators
can you go over here and show us where
you were when this happened
he explains that after approaching jones
vehicle jones
threatened him with a gun that's when
raja says he used deadly force
in self-defense and i immediately said
hey man police can i help you and at
which point that's when he's jumped back
and i saw him draw the gun right at me
right after i said the word police and
it was just like
then i was young i was like drop the gun
dropped and i saw him go like this
and and i remember saying to myself
aim i still remember and i was like aim
and i put that front sight right in the
center mass
and i squeezed i i think i believe two
rounds
okay and while we've got audio of what
transpired
we don't have video of what corey jones
did or did not do inside that car
we don't know at what point officer
roger became aware that jones had a gun
we don't know what jones did with that
gun we don't know if jones pointed it
at raja and when he may have pointed it
at rogers so
there is room in this for some form of
self-defense
argument and it just
immediately it's like a positive
it's just like you know your family
flashed in front of your kids flashed in
front of you and you're just like
this and just and i immediately just
shouted
drop the gun
take a deep breath let's do this okay
there clearly is are signs of very
typical stress
um likely officer raja has has been
sleepless
um he is experiencing the trauma of a
very traumatic
incident and there's evidence of that
where he breaks down briefly
emotionally he's he's very passionate
about what happened and that's very very
common um but i i sense a
an over emphasis on certain facts that
that may be designed to help officer
raja and his story
because you could clearly argue that
he is lying during that recap with the
detectives
and i immediately got out of the band
and he's like i'm okay i'm okay man
and at which point i said hey man police
can i help you a second i said police he
jumped back
and i clearly remember him drawing and
going
pointing a gun at me but let's go back
to jones roadside assistance call
capturing the moments right before the
[Music]
shooting
[Music]
did raja in fact identify himself as law
enforcement
and did jones have any idea that raja
was an officer
the roadside assistance call is rather
damning
clearly a police officer who's acting
consistently with his duties
one of the first things they would do is
clearly identify themselves particularly
if they're in plain clothes
particularly if they have no emergency
equipment activated on their
civilian vehicle that they're driving as
raja was doing with this white cargo van
so we have an absence and there should
have been repeated
identifications can you imagine being
stranded on the side of the road at
three o'clock in the morning how
vulnerable
that must be corey jones who is
a young man with no criminal history
whatsoever
complete law-abiding citizen nobody
doubts for a second
cory jones believed that was a police
officer giving a lawful
command that he would not have
acquiesced
okay is there a reason why you stopped
here instead of pulling up
because the guy jumped the guy jumped
out he jumped out exactly while you were
in the car he jumped down
he jumped out and i immediately jumped
out too
you were dressed exactly like that
exactly more nothing less
exactly exactly exactly like this and i
had my holster
which was covered you know the reason
why
cop cars have all of the lights and the
protect and serve
and the numbers and the reason why you
know
cops wear these uniforms is to make it
very clear to the public
who they are to prevent this exact
situation
otherwise someone who you know cuts you
off in the middle of the night
and approaches you with a gun is just
some stranger how would you
know him as law enforcement corey jones
did absolutely
nothing wrong and in fact he was a
positive pillar of society he was a
musician
he was a family man cory family believes
he went to his grave never knowing who
this strange
person was who was confronting him
[Music]
i see his whole body spin and i saw like
a flash a silver flash of like a
metallic flash
come at me and in my head i immediately
said
aim aim and i was like and i was like
and i just picked that front sight right
in the center mass and i just
florida officer nouman raja shot and
killed motorist corey jones
after what he claimed was an armed
confrontation as questions arose about
why raja was so quick to pull the
trigger many wondered
if race played a factor you
cannot get away from the elephant in the
room that he was a young
african-american man who had a permit to
carry a gun
this is the person who committed a crime
and should be held accountable
regardless of the fact that he is a
police officer
i don't believe based on the facts and
circumstances that this was a racially
motivated
crime but i do believe that raja's
implicit biases triggered a reaction
within him
that registered jones as a deadly threat
and this is exactly why officers need to
be better trained on how to identify
their own implicit biases and how to
remove them from their decision making
processes
despite raja's claims that this was
self-defense
his version of events was contradicted
by other evidence
particularly jones roadside assistance
call
raja was eventually charged with
manslaughter by culpable negligence
and attempted first degree murder for
the rounds that miss
jones that's how law enforcement
officers are trained
it's about center of mass neutralizing
the threat you're not trained to kill
you're trained to neutralize the threat
once that threat's been neutralized
you keep firing you've got an intent
other than dealing with the threat
an ordinary citizen would have been
facing far more
serious charges he should have been
charged with obstruction of justice for
lying to investigators
but because raja was an officer acting
in the scope of his duty
i think that manslaughter by culpable
negligence was the most appropriate
charge to ensure
jones got justice in this case raja's
defense team first tried to get the
charges dropped
by arguing that florida's stand your
ground law applies
the courts disagreed and the case moved
forward
florida's stand your ground law is
definitely very interesting
it grants immunity to defendants to
defend themselves
with necessary even lethal force when
they believe they are in imminent
danger there's no duty to retreat
raja is trying to have it both ways he's
trying to say and i was a cop
acting as a cop i was on duty but you
know
if you don't think i was then i'm a
civilian and i have stand floor to stand
your ground
to defend myself with well poor to stand
your ground
doesn't say that you can create a hot
mess
that you never should have done in the
first place
raja's trial became a back and forth
with the prosecution arguing
the defendant carelessly shot an
innocent person to death
that's a verdict finding him guilty as
charge
of being a reckless killer
and for trying to murder corey jones and
tried to cover it up there's a huge
difference between
trying to think about what happened
intentionally saying something
they'll get away with what you did
while the defense said raja reasonably
perceived a threat
it was a perfect storm that turned
deadly
mr jones pointed that handgun
mr raja in defending himself
fired his handgun and that he didn't lie
about what happened
but rather the trauma and chaos of the
event
caused him to misremember details the
stress of the incident
can impact how they
perceive and relate the incident
they don't always get everything right
interestingly during the trial
raja chose not to testify which is
surprising considering we've seen
defendants take the stand in
self-defense cases
we should never be drawing any adverse
inference
simply because someone exercises their
right not to testify
nevertheless if raja and his attorneys
felt that he had a
plausible legitimate story to tell
about lawful police activity then they
should have felt
comfortable telling that story and
something about
raj's story made them uncomfortable
as the count one we find a defendant
guilty of manslaughter
while armed with a firearm as to count
two
we found a defendant guilty of attempted
first-degree murder as charged in the
information
nouman raja became the first florida
police officer in
30 years to be convicted for an on-duty
shooting
because of my background i do give
benefit of the doubt to the officers who
have
a very tough job on the street and need
to survive
every day and i think juries believe
that too and i
i think without this audio of the
roadside assistance call
we would have assumed he was telling us
the truth and i think he would have
gotten off
raja may have been found guilty but what
happens next for him
but since no amount of punishment can
bring corey back
no amount of punishment for killing him
could be too much
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all
good evening and welcome this is a
complicated case don't
really jump to conclusions welcome to
prime crime tonight
another day of drama between both sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original
and compelling programming the law and
crime network is
everywhere and we invite you inside the
jury box
this is law and crime
i think all court shows are the same
we're talking about your father guilty
or not guilty guilty think again
judge caprio rules with common sense i
was having contractions i was rushing to
the hospital
inspector quinn what does justice demand
jail
and compassion i'm going to take the
circumstances into consideration
the best court experience i've had
clearly judge he's been in a court
before
get caught in providence
nouman raja was convicted of
manslaughter and attempted murder
for the shooting death of corey jones on
the side of a west palm beach freeway
now it became a question of sentencing
for the former police officer
statements from family members further
showed the complications of this story
no one was there to hold his hand to
comfort him
or to save his life he was alone
but god is helping us through this the
person that we trusted to serve and
protect did not
he hunted down an innocent man and
killed him
he ruined the lives of corey jones's
family
as well as his own and still he shows
not an
ounce of remorse nouman raja is a
disgrace to honorable members of law
enforcement
someone said that he embarrassed his
family no he didn't
we're proud of them once again i'm
really sorry for corey jones family
family's lost so i would like to
apologize to the family
but i just don't feel this is right it's
politically motivated
i have my husband a man who was faced
with a split second decision
something that neither you nor i nor
most people in this room will thankfully
have
to face i also know that the future
of two innocent children linger and the
lenience of this court
their lives are forever changed forever
scarred
raja was sentenced to 25 years in prison
25 years is a tough tough road
but i have to tell you it's consistent
with the evidence
in this case at the time of this taping
raja has appealed his case his lawyers
are pushing several arguments
such as that raja employed justifiable
use of force as an officer
and the court failed to instruct the
jury on raja's attempts at making an
arrest
most people don't succeed on appeals
anyway
but with raja his previous stand your
ground appeal did not succeed
so i'm not sure how he's going to prove
justifiable use of force
following everything we know to be true
all of these potential defenses that
raja may attempt to use
in his appeal are fraught with peril for
him
if you're going to say i was trying to
attempt an arrest that requires facts
you can't claim you're making an arrest
when we never heard it on the audio
i'm going to have to prove that i was
acting as a police officer
and i haven't done that successfully at
the trial level
i think the message here has been sent
in the state of florida
that police officers will be held
accountable
for their actions when they use deadly
force that cannot be explained
there's a lot at play in the nouman raja
story but what's interesting to think
about is that in this case
by making that roadside assistance call
corey jones
caught his own killer that's all we have
for you here on prime crime
leave us your comments on instagram and
twitter with the hashtag primecrime
as always thank you for joining us and
until next time be safe
[Music]
you